here's what would happen if the sun was
smaller than Earth
a small Sun wouldn't be able to create
fusion and would burn out completely our
solar system would lose its only star
and since the sun is the source of
gravity that keeps us all in orbit all
the planets Earth included would float
away into space in search of another
anchor that's no happy ending for life
on Earth so instead let's increase the
size of Earth to be bigger than the Sun
is now Earth's mass would be at least
000 times bigger than it is now a planet
this big would generate enough heat and
pressure in its core to become a star
itself so of course there would be no
life left on this hot star life could
possibly evolve on other planets or even
the moon but in either of these
scenarios life on Earth would have no
chance of survival because